we are back with none other
than vin diesel give it up
now is a look at his new movie f9 so
what's dom up to you know in this fast
and furious installment what are you
doing this one's fascinating because
what we one of the things that
you want to do when you're um
involved in in creating a franchise like this a
mythology is to try to defy expectations and what
we all know about dom tereto is his loyalty to
family at all cost what we discover in this one
and the reason why we discover it is because he's
a father now and when you whenever you have kids
you reflect on your own yeah you start going wait
what did that mean and what you know we we look
at our parents in a different prison once we
become parents and we need to do that to better be
parents right what our goal in life every parent
in the world wakes up in the morning thinking
how can i be a better parent it's
common it's all of us i hope that's true
but i believe that to be do so in looking
in reflecting on that and actually going
what's interesting about fast nine is that we
go back to the first franchise to the first
film to that iconic moment where he's talking
about why he's so scared of the car to paul walker
and we actually uncover that scenario and what
that means and we find a broken brotherhood yeah
and that broken brotherhood is what comes to haunt
dom in fastnine oh wow well speaking of family um
your son's in it right vincent yes my son isn't
that's okay so is it terrifying because you're
like i hope he does well i want him to do well
but at the same time is he terrified because you
know you're he doesn't get terrified too much oh
he's falling his new kids are very very bold he's
actually he just the other day presented a new car
company to justin and i and assets both to invest
in it so oh my gosh that kid yeah wow he um so
here's i didn't invite him to play a role in this
the fast family is so truly a family that i'm
working with justin lynn the day he was born so
i say goodbye to justin lynn get on a plane go to
new york and receive my son that's ten years ago
so when we're filming so he they obviously grown
to be family themselves they know each other yeah
and justin thought it would be a good idea for
him to play younger dom but i didn't necessarily
think it would be a great idea because it's
a scene that i'm in did you see the movie yet
yeah no i haven't when you see the movie it all
makes sense thank you yeah so i'm in the zone
and there was this magical moment of that day
and you as an artist will identify with this
the whole time he's in this scene and his father's
not there dom toretto is there but his dad isn't
coaching him because i'm so in the pocket i'm so
in the moment and there was a moment when we got
home and i saw that he saw that dom was no longer
there and that his father was there and i saw a
little smile on his face he's like hello just yeah
it was a special moment but that's a cool thing to
share though with your son that's a really amazing
moment it is because i i didn't have to crutch him
first of all justin was going to cover him
entirely justin lin the director but he also saw
how much how sacred the process has to be to
create to elevate a movie you know to create
a movie of that magnitude characters that the
world is so familiar with yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box forever help